المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه تصريحات
المسؤولين الايرانيين عن التوصل الى صفقه
لتبادل السجناء معتبرا انها كذبه اخرى حسب
تعبيره وتزيد من معاناه عائلاتهم
في بيان ان بلاده تعمل بلا كلل من اجل
تامين اطلاق سراح الامريكيين الثلاثه
المحتجزين بشكل جائر في ايران على حد
تعبيره وشدد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه على النواصمتون لن تتوقف الى ان
يتحقق لم شمل المحتجزين الامريكيين في
ايران بعائلاتهم في سياق نفسه قال متحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القوميه الامريكي ان
ادعاءات المسؤولين الايرانيين عن التوصل
الى اتفاق للافراج عن الامريكيين
المحتجزين في ايران بشكل جائر كاذبه حسب
تعبيره واشار المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي كان المسؤولين الايرانيين
لن يترددوا في اختلاق الامور وان مزاعم
ايران الاخيره ستسبب مزيدا من الحزن
لعائلات المحتجزين الامريكيين كما قال
هذا وكان وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين
امير عبد الله قد قال ان بلاده توصلت الى
اتفاق لتبادل السجناء مع واشنطن خلال
الايام الماضيه واضاف في مقابله تلفزيونيه
ان بلاده جاهزه من طرفها لتبادل السجناء
وان الولايات المتحده تقوم بالتنسيقات
التقنيه وافقت تعبيره
تواصلنا مع الولايات المتحده خلال الايام
الماضيه الى اتفاق بشان مساله تبادل
السجناء واذا كانت كافه الامور جيده من
جانب الولايات المتحده اعتقد باننا سنشهد
خلال مده قصيره تبادل السجناء بين البلدين
هذا الملف انساني ومنذ مارس العام الماضي
وقعنا وثيقه مع واشنطن بشكل غير مباشر في
هذا الشان لكن ارضيه تنفيذ هذا التفاهم
باتت متاحه الان جاهزون من طرفنا والجانب
الامريكي يقوم بالتنسيق اللازم
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضموا الينا من
طهران براس الجزيره عمر هواش ومن واشنطن
مراسله الجزيره بيسان ابو كويك نبدا اولا
معك عمر اذا هناك نفي من المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه
للتصريحات المسؤولين الايرانيين على
التوصل الى صفقه لتبادل السجناء من ردود
فعل في ايران على ذلك
جمال حتى الان لا ردود فعل على ذلك لكن
خلال الفتره الاخيره ومنذ التوقف
المفاوضات النوويه بين طهران واربع زائد
واحد من خلفها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كانت تؤكد طهران دائما على ان هناك تبادل
الرسائل جاري بينها وبين واشنطن عبر وسط
عبر اطراف ثالثه وتؤكد حصول تقدم في هذه
الرسائل او تقدم في المفاوضات النوويه
وكان ياتي دائما الرد الامريكي على ان
المفاوضات متوقفه وانه لا يوجد هناك تبادل
للرسائل وكانت طهران ترد على ان ذلك ان في
الامريكي هو جزء من سياسه التناقض
الامريكيه اللا واقعيه الامريكيه الكيل
بمكيالين مثلما تقول الخارجيه الايرانيه
او المسؤولون الايرانيون دائما في الملف
الجديد اليوم وهو مساله تبادل السجناء من
المحتمل ان يكون ذلك يتكرر طهران تؤكد
يا طهران قد تعتبر ذلك جزءا من تناقض
المواقف الامريكيه لكن هناك احتمال اخر
جمال قبل ايام تحديدا يوم الخميس الماضي
كان هناك لقاء فريد من نوعه اجراه احد
السجناء الامريكيين في طهران من سجن ايفين
في العاصمه الايرانيه اتصال هاتفي مع قناه
امريكيه محطه سي ان قرئ ذلك الاتصال الذي
وجه فيه السجين الامريكي صيامك نماذى
رساله الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى
الرئيس جوبادن مطالبا اياه بالافراج وعدم
النسيان ملف السجناء قرا هذا الاتصال او
سماح طهران لاسجيل الامريكيه لاجراء هكذا
اتصال نادر على انه محاوله من طهران للضغط
على امريكا على الاداره الامريكيه وحتى
على الراي العام داخل امريكا لاجل تفعيل
هذا الملف تذكير الامريكيين بان لديهم
ثلاث سجناء على الاقل في سجون الامريكيه
وان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي من
تعيق التوصل الى صفقه لتبادل السجناء
قراءه كذلك ما صرح به اليوم حسين امير عبد
الالهيان وفق ما يقول بعض المتابعون هنا
بانه محاوله جديده للضغط على الولايات
المتحده للتذكير بهذا الملف وتقليب الراي
العام داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لاجل الضغط على ادارتهم للافراج عن
السجناء الامريكيين داخل طهران نحن نعرف
ان لدى ايران ثلاثه سجناء امريكيين
معروفون بالنسبه لدينا وكذلك هناك في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نحو ثمانيه او
عشر سجناء على الاقل ايرانيون معتقلون
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك
اتفاق او مسوده اتفاق منذ مارس الماضي
اشار اليها اليوم حسين امير عبد وزير
الخارجيه الايراني قال انه تم التوصل
اليها وان كل شيء جاهز فقط يتبقى بعض
الخطوات التقنيه الامريكيه لاجل الدفع
قدما بهذه المسوده وتحويلها الى اتفاق
عملي على الارض وعندما تتحدث طهران عن
خطوات تقنيه في هذا المجال يعني بالدرجه
الاولى مساله الاموال الايرانيه المجمده
خلال الصفقات التي حصلت سواء في عهد
اوباما في عهد ترامب كان هناك حديث عن
افراج عن اموال ايرانيه مجمده الى جانب
تبادل السجناء هناك نحو سبع مليارات اقل
شيء عند ايران عند كوريا الجنوبيه اموال
مجمده فعل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وعقوبات واشنطن على طيران لذلك تؤكد ايران
على ان هذه الصفقه ينبغي ان تتم تقول ان
على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تتحلى
بالواقعيه الاراده اللازمه لاجل تنفيذ
هكذا صفحه
ابو كويك في واشنطن هذا النفي الذي صدر عن
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان تكون هناك صفقه هل هو بالمطلقه ام ان
هناك مباحثات جاريه عن طريق اطراف طرف
ثالث مثلا
المطلق
حتى اللحظه ما ورد على لسان المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه وايضا متحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي في البيت الابيض نفي قاطع
بان هناك اتفاق قد تم
التوصل له وهو رد مباشر على تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه الايراني
وتم وصف هذه
التصريحات بالكذب القاسيه التي لا تخدم
الا زياده معاناه عائلات اولئك السجناء
وهناك ثلاثه سجناء
امريكيين امريكيين من اصول ايرانيه في
ايران ايضا ما قاله المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي بان ايران لا تتوانى عن
اختلاق الامور ولكنهم شددوا على انهم
يعملون وهذه التصريحات متطابقه من
الخارجيه ومن البيت ابيض بان الاداره تعمل
دون كلل للافراج عن اولئك السجناء لذا
في هذا الكلام بمضمونه ربما اشاره الى انه
ربما هناك محادثات وكان هناك جمال ما نقل
قبل اسابيع بان المحادثات بالفعل موجوده
محادثات غير مباشره وكان هناك تصريحات
لمتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه في حينه
قبل نحو ثلاثه اسابيع بانه لن يعلق على
العمر نظرا لحساسيه الامور لذا ان في ليس
تحديدا حول قضيه المحادثات من عدمها هو
النفي بان هناك
اتفاق وان هذا التصريح الايراني بان
الاتفاق تم التوصل اليه هو كذب وكذب قاسيه
كما يعني التعبير الذي استخدم تحديدا من
قبل الخارجيه الامريكيه ومجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي التابع للبيت الابيض وكان
الرد هو تحديدا هل كان هناك اتفاق فكان
الرد بان هذه تصريحات كاذبه ومغلوطه ولا
مكان لها من الصحه ولكن الاداره الامريكيه
تشدد على التزامها بالافراج عن اولئك
السجناء وانها تعمل على ذلك دون كلل شكرا
ابو كويك مراسل جزيره في واشنطن وشكرا
كذلك لعمر هواش نورس الجزيره في طهران